(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we are exploring the question,
what are our top 10 most
influential TV shows?
- Yeah so over the course of our lives,
we've watched our fair
share of television,
and it's interesting 'cause I
started thinking about this,
at certain pockets of
my life I was watching
a lot more television,
and at other times less.
And so, I think that my
list, which I have not shared
with you and you have not
shared your top 10 list with me.
- That's what we're about
to do as a matter of fact.
- Oh we're gonna do that and
share it with you, listener.
It was really a truckin'
back down memory lane,
you know, and I was pleasantly surprised
by the things that came
up when I started thinking
about television shows
that not only influenced me
in terms of like my creative brain,
but also in terms of my
life, just personal impact.
- [Rhett] Mm-hmm.
- So this is not necessarily
our favorite television shows,
but it kind of is.
I have a lot of honorable mentions.
- Well I would say most significant.
I would be most significant in our lives.
That's not as clear and
easy to say as influential.
- Right, but this is not
what we believe to be
our top 10 best television
shows of all time.
- No, not even close.
- These are ones that we
have personal connections to
in one form or another
which we can flesh out
as we go through these things.
- So while we did not share
the list with one another,
the one thing that we did do
just so you can understand
the exercise is that
we did tell each other
that we would be going
back through our lives,
so it was kinda going back
to the first television shows
you could remember being significant
and then I kinda just, I
went through my entire life--
- Okay.
I didn't do it that way but--
- That's, what I'm saying
is, just to give you an idea
where they come from.
Some are gonna be when we were
kids, some are more recent.
Not too many.
- All of mine are current.
No just kidding.
But the reason why I thought
to have this conversation was
because something happened over the break
that I chose not to share with
you a couple of weeks back
when I was giving my
update on the holiday break
and my family time.
- Mm-hmm.
- And when I went to Sedona so
the thing I didn't tell you,
something very special happened
that our family bonded over something
and it was the reality competition
show known as Survivor.
Have you heard of this show?
- This is a little weird.
- It is a little weird, isn't it?
But it turns out Survivor
became a very special part
of my family's holiday break
in a very unanticipated
bonding experience.
- You know, whatever it
takes, man. (chuckles)
- Exactly.
- Whatever it takes
to get everybody together.
- Exactly.
And a magical thing happened,
but a little back story.
When we were on tour in Australia,
we went back to our rooms.
When we were in Sydney, we were
in that high rise apartment.
- Yeah, high livin'.
- Towards the end of that,
the Sydney part of the trip,
there was this one night
where we were like, let's just order in.
You kinda get to a point in
your trip where you're like,
I just don't think we can
mobilize everybody to go out
to eat again and I feel a little over it,
so we just stayed in the
room and ordered pizza.
And I put on the
television, I was like hey,
let's watch some Australian television.
You had been talking about
how nice everybody was.
You were learning a lot about the culture.
- I was.
Very, very nice.
- I was like, well,
the Neals need to do that
too so we turned it on
and it was the Australian
version of Survivor
just happened to be on and I'm like,
kids, this is, look at
this, it's Survivor.
And they're like, what?
And I was like, well it's
basically a game show.
It's a reality competition show.
Basically, I was having trouble.
American Idol and The Voice
are reality competition shows
where people sing but it turns
out that these other ones
where they take a group of
people and they just strand 'em
out on an island or something.
- They had never heard of this concept?
- They had never heard
of Survivor at any point.
- I would have thought that
Survivor was like in memes
or something, in some way.
There's some way kids
find out about things.
- I just don't think it's cool
enough for that. (chuckles)
I couldn't have told you that
Survivor was still going on
but lo and behold here it was,
and this was the Australian
version of Survivor
but it happened to be an episode
where they were bringing in
I think heroes and villains
from previous Survivors.
- Oh they're already there
in Australia as well.
- Well one of the guys was from America,
a famous guy who I won't mention
'cause I can't remember his
name but he's from another--
- Are Americans as cool to Australians
as Australians are to America?
Could you sense that in the
way that they set him up?
- It was one of the first
episodes of the season
and they voted the guy off so
I'll put it to you that way.
- Okay apparently not.
So apparently you have a correct
understanding of Americans.
- But I was like, oh, you
don't know about Survivor
so we just started watching it.
We just watched the one
episode out of context
and everybody, I just made a mental note,
everybody seemed to be into it.
- Yeah.
- They're asking questions
about how Survivor works as
a game and stuff like that
so I just made a mental note,
got back to the States--
- Jeff Probst was not involved.
- No.
- Directly.
- No he was not hosting.
He was not directly involved.
I get back here, we're like,
we're filming a couple
weeks ago and I think Kevin
brought up something about
Survivor and I was like,
hold on, were you just
talking about Survivor?
And he was like, yeah John
and I are big Survivor fans.
If you see the two of us,
or maybe somebody else,
trying to, if you see
the two of them together,
I can guarantee they're
talking about Survivor
and I was like, I would
have laughed at you--
- Two weeks ago.
- Before my Australian
trip but the funny thing
that happened and I told him
the story, and they were like.
I was like, I think we should
start watching Survivor.
I think my family would be into it.
He was like, oh, you definitely should.
It's amazing, and they're
getting both into it
and I'm like you guys are
dorks, but okay, whatever.
- Yeah definitely.
- And they said you should watch the
Millennials vs. Gen X
season which was like
three seasons ago so pretty recent.
- It's still going.
- Said it's really good.
There's like 400 seasons of this thing.
No literally I think
there's like 36 seasons.
It is still going.
I didn't even know it.
- Twice a year
for almost 20 years I guess.
- So the week leading up to our trip,
the kids are getting out of school,
school work's dying down,
I start putting on the Survivor
and everybody gets into it.
Like every single member of the family.
It's so hard to pick out a
movie or a television show
that everybody can get into.
But Lando loved it because
it was like adventurous
and outdoors and oh, that
one's in Fiji where we went.
- Right.
- So I was like,
we been to Fiji, we've experienced kinda,
well we were like at a resort.
They're not at a resort.
- Not exactly the same thing.
- Lincoln, he loves strategy games.
He loves strategy so he's into that.
Lily really enjoyed the
humor of kinda laughing
at these people basically
becoming characters.
And Christy really enjoyed all of it.
I don't know exactly what Christy loved
but I think--
- She likes the guys
with the shirts off.
- Guys with the shirts
off, there was a model.
A male model.
- Of course she does.
- And--
- Survivor body they call it.
- And I liked the production.
I would pause Survivor and I would say,
"Guys, do you see how
brilliant the production is?"
Rhett, they have it down, I
know this sounds ludicrous--
- No no no.
- They have it down
to a science.
- What's ludicrous is pausing
and explaining it to your family.
Appreciating it, no I am
totally on the same page.
- I was just overflowing with joy.
- It's a production wonder
but we've talked about this,
in fact, we've talked about
this very specifically--
- It's that Dad thing.
- You can't be the,
I do the same thing, you cannot be the dad
who makes your family stop
and acknowledge how awesome something is
because you think it's awesome.
You have to just give it to
'em and let them experience it
on their own terms.
No more pausing.
- They each had their
thing but I was trying
to get them to appreciate
what I appreciate
which was after all of these seasons,
they've got, I mean, the contestants,
some of them are obsessed
with game player Survivor
so they're really good at
it and they invent new ways
to play it and new strategies come out,
but the way that they present
it in terms of the editing
and they bring story out and
you have these character arcs
is masterful, I mean it really
is amazing to me. (chuckles)
And so it's, I might have to alter my list
and put Survivor on there.
It is an honorable--
- So hold on.
You're saying Survivor
is not, after all this,
Survivor is not on your list?
- (chuckles) It should be now because
it just seems so fresh, I
don't know if it's gonna stand
the test of time 'cause
every night at Sedona
we would do hiking and
everything I talked about
but then we would also be
talking about Survivor.
We had something that everybody
could talk about together
during the day and then
at night we'd be like,
hey let's all get all in our
PJs and let's make some popcorn
and let's sit down and
have our Survivor session.
Like everybody was into it,
and while we were hiking,
Christy and I were like wow,
this is a rare gem of a moment.
Thank you Jeff Probst.
- And so are you, how much
do you watch in a sitting?
- We would watch two or three episodes.
- Wow.
- In a sitting.
And so we finished it the night before
we were leaving Sedona and they were like
let's watch another one.
So we're out to dinner and I'm googling
what are the best seasons of Survivor?
There's this very involved Reddit thread,
a Survivor Reddit thread
where people talk about
what are the best seasons
and which ones to watch
and this one's the best but you have
to watch this one before
because it spoils something
about the strategy so,
I figured all that out
and we're like we're gonna watch China,
and so we come back and we
start watching it and I'm like--
- What are you watching
it on, what platform?
- A laptop.
- No what platform?
- Like a coffee table?
No I'm messing with you.
Hulu.
Hulu has Survivor, all of 'em.
- Okay.
- And I immediately notice,
people are gushing about
how great this season is.
I never watched it.
The only season I had
watched was, Christy and I,
like in our second year of
marriage we watched season three
Survivor: Outback Australia
and there was a goat farmer.
He was very funny.
That's the only season we watched.
- And I think that it was, it
was a phenomenon at that time.
Jessie and I watched multiple seasons.
It was appointment television.
- Yeah season two was like
the number one show on television.
- I remember when it came out--
- But I didn't watch that one.
- Just thinking it was like,
this is changing everything!
- Yeah.
- And we had to watch it.
And then I don't remember what happened.
- Reality competition shows
really became mainstream.
- Just fell off.
- Then on the back end
of that, Christy and I are
watching things like The Mole,
hosted by Anderson Cooper.
- Yep.
- That was weird, like Amazing Race.
But anyway, we started
watching the China one,
everybody's excited.
It was the night after watching the finale
and having a big moment,
this sense of closure.
First thing I noticed, ooh, it's in 4:3.
Not widescreen.
- Going back.
- This episode that Reddit
said was one of the best ones
was 4:3, and this is much earlier so,
the things that they no
longer do on Survivor
they did in that season which
was like, I can't even--
- Hold on did you go finish it?
- Well I'll skip to the chase
and say we didn't even
finish that episode.
(sighs)
(whistles)
- I don't think you can call
yourself a real Survivor freak.
Or what do they call themselves?
- I didn't do that.
- You wanna do the Reddit thread.
Did you subscribe to the Reddit thread?
- No.
But I had my hopes up but I realized
they were explaining more
that we already knew,
like why are these people,
Jeff was doing these voiceovers
like everyone came in their own clothes
not knowing that we're about
to take away their luggage.
They don't even do that crap anymore.
They're like let's get to the game.
People are coming in,
they're like the Gen Xers
are coming in on this boat
and the Millennials are coming
and they're like cutting
to interview footage
about how the cultures are
different and it's masterful.
But they've gotten over
all the crap of like,
you just expect the
business guy is gonna be
in a business suit and you're
not gonna ask any questions.
It's part of the game.
It literally has become
much more of a game show
than something that they
had to motivate in reality
all the things that were
happening if that makes sense.
It moved, the setup took longer.
And you get attached to these characters
and then they're gone and you gotta start
from scratch all over.
- So what season are
you drawing the line at?
What's acceptable?
- We haven't come back to it
because I just feel like we'll
never recapture the magic
of you know--
- You let 4:3 ruin your whole
family's bonding experience.
- Well I added the other thing.
I think the cadence of Survivor,
you gotta go away from it
for a little bit.
- Oh.
- So we're like let's just--
- We can handle it twice a year.
- "I've heard lots of good
things about The Good Place,"
Christy says, "Let's
watch The Good Place."
- Yeah a little different, different vibe.
- So now we as a family are
hooked on The Good Place.
So I actually think that television,
we're now discovering
our kids are of an age
that they're enjoying things
that I actually enjoy.
And I'll get to one on
my list which will lead
to more conversation about
this but yeah Lando's younger
but because I mean, Lily's almost 16.
Lincoln's almost 14.
They're developing a
sense of humor that is,
we can watch the same stuff and enjoy it.
Like two years ago we would
watch The Flash when it came out
'cause they were really
into that, you know?
- Difficult to--
- And yeah Lily's into Teen Wolf and--
- To stick around for that.
- Was Dr. Who,
now it's like Teen Wolf and
some other shows like that
that I really don't care for.
- I can take a season of The Flash,
you know what I'm saying?
- Oh I enjoyed The Flash.
I enjoyed watching it with
them but I didn't enjoy it
for myself that much.
- Right, yeah yeah yeah.
- But now we're getting into
comedies that we can watch,
like The Good Place,
we're all watching it,
we're having a blast.
- My wife and children watched that,
started that without me,
so now I just kinda get in where I fit in.
Not quite the same.
- Yeah you gotta start at the beginning.
You gotta watch it straight through.
- What am I gonna do now though?
Gonna be a guy in the attic
watching TV by himself?
- You can't watch The
Good Place piecemeal.
You gotta watch it as a linear,
chronological experience.
- Yeah.
- But you know, I'm reacquainting
myself with television
in a way, like I haven't
watched sitcoms for years.
Again, I'll get into
some of this in my list
but I'm just, I'm figuring
out that the television,
and this may sound sad, is actually,
it's a great tool to bring
us together as a family
and I was missing it.
Because of Survivor, and
I think we will go back
to Survivor but it's gonna,
let's go through a few more shows.
And then we can come back to it.
- It happened over the holidays.
We'll move on in a second
but when are you finding this time?
So you scheduling it?
Weekends, when is this happening?
How are you getting everybody together
to watch television at the same time?
- Before, I mean, after
dinner, before bedtime.
So like that eight to nine o'clock.
- Is this happening once a week?
Is this happening--
- I haven't scheduled it.
- How often does it happen?
- They don't have a lot of homework yet.
- Yeah that's the thing--
- Just gearing up.
It'll probably fizzle and it might just be
a weekend thing where it's like hey,
instead of watching a movie,
let's binge watch four episodes
of whatever show that we can all agree on.
Because a movie, a movie is one and done.
It's basically impossible for
us to all agree on a movie.
- Hmm.
- That's probably not true
but I don't have a good list
of comedies.
- We've had some good movie
experiences, but I get it.
- But the television experience,
the way that it continues to grow.
There's episodes so you
can have conversations
and talk about it at dinner
and then come back to it
as opposed to a movie.
- Talking about Survivor at dinner.
Invite me over next time.
(both laugh)
Okay we are gonna talk about these top 10
most influential
television shows but first,
I'm gonna talk about the
top four most influential
wristbands that I'm wearing.
Now, you been looking at my wrist.
I know, those of you watching.
And you're like--
- Well you're only talking
to people watching.
- Well some people turn the
video on and just listen.
(clicks tongue) I heard about that.
- Is that right, you heard about that?
- Yeah yeah, heard
about it, didn't see it.
I'm not making a fashion statement
unless you think I should be.
I just wanted to show you
the four available colors
of the Mythical wristband.
It is a polymer of some kind.
Smells like rubber.
- Get you some.
- They'll fit around--
- Where would they get it?
- Most every wrist.
Mythical.store.
One size fits all.
Once size fits most.
- There's other stuff too.
There's pins, there's pop sockets.
- I doubt they would fit
like Andre the Giant.
Can you imagine how big his wrist was?
- Right now?
- Well probably fit it now
'cause he's probably
just a shriveled bone.
Why did I say that?
I mean, that's--
- I don't think the bones shrivel.
- Yeah.
Mythical.store.
Okay--
- So let's get into these lists.
So what, do you have
any honorable mentions?
You wanna start with number 10?
We're gonna go back and forth.
- I had honorable mentions.
But I have a feeling that some of the ones
that made our lists
might be in each other's
honorable mentions and
let's just, if that happens,
it happens, but I don't wanna mention 'em.
- Yeah that's a good point.
- Let's make 'em honorable,
let's not mention 'em.
- All right gimme, let's start
with your number 10, brother.
- Number 10, The A-Team.
- Oh crap.
- One of the reasons I was
thinking about The A-Team
is the way that my phone works.
- Uh-huh.
- When I plug my phone
into my car, it
automatically starts playing
the first song, often, I
don't know when it decides
to do this, often begins
playing the first song
in my entire library which
by alphabetical order
is The A-Team, and so, and I
think I've talked about this
on the show before because
you've gotten into my car--
- We're like having a serious conversation
coming back from a meeting
and all of a sudden--
- In 1972, a crack
commando unit was sent to--
(Link chuckles)
- Yeah 'cause--
- They're now known as
soldiers of fortune.
If you can find them
and you know, whatever,
I can't remember it.
I've heard it so many times
and I haven't memorized it
but I was actually in the car
with Shepherd the other day
and it started playing and he
was like, what is that, Dad?
He was very interested.
- Oh yeah.
- So I began to tell him about The A-Team,
which, again, this was a
team of former military guys
put together, they had
a van driven by Mr. T
who played B.A. Baracus.
And they would just get into stuff.
Nobody ever actually got hurt
because it was a network television show
but the reason that it was so--
- There were guns involved
but no one got shot.
- The reason that it
made my list is because,
not as much as another one
that's higher up on my list--
- Oh yeah.
- But it is a show
that defined the way that I
interacted with television
as a child, meaning there was a,
you probably remember
specific nights and times
because that's how your brain works.
I don't remember, but I
do remember that there was
a specific night and a specific time
where we had to be at the television
between the years of 1983
to 1987 to watch The A-Team
and my brother and I most of the time
would watch it together
in that span of our lives.
- I remember watching
A-Team more as reruns,
and I actually don't think I
was hooked on it in real time.
I don't know what happened.
But I did love it, when I watched it.
But I remember watching it during the day
so it must have been later.
- You know it's also I
found it to be this perfect,
at the time, I'm sure
it doesn't hold up well,
but at the time it was
this perfect mix of comedy
and action and also you actually cared
about what was happening.
Because just the way that
these guys interacted
with each other, it was
like there was a lot
of laugh out loud moments and
the way Hannibal had his cigar
and said, "I love it when--"
- [Both] "A plan comes together."
- And whenever they'd
have to fly somewhere,
they'd have to knock Mr. T out
because he was afraid of flying.
They'd have to knock him out.
- Yeah, sedative.
- And Murdock,
he was mentally ill.
I mean I don't think
you could do that today.
I didn't watch the movie.
Did you watch the movie?
- No.
I don't ruin things--
- Bradley Cooper played Face--
- That makes sense.
- In that movie.
I mean I might watch anything
Bradley Cooper's in now,
so I might go back and
watch The A-Team movie.
- Yeah so that's my number 10.
- My number 10 is Mister
Rogers' Neighborhood.
So I didn't go chronological
for all of this,
but it just ended up at number 10.
This man who was so schedule-oriented,
you know and routine, his
routine was impeccable.
He always changed his shoes
and he always changed his sweater
and he always spoke directly to me.
I think that's something
that, I think that's the key
to Good Mythical Morning
is how we speak directly
to one viewer and I'm gonna
credit Mister Rogers for that
because I watched Sesame
Street religiously
and then Mister Rogers'
Neighborhood would come on
after it at my babysitter's
house when I was like four
or five, as early as I can remember.
- [Rhett] Right.
- But that was a meaningful connection.
I had a relationship with Mister Rogers.
- I watched the documentary.
What year did that stop?
Did you--
- It kept going for a long
time but I did outgrow it.
- You outgrew it.
- I did outgrow it.
- I was a fan like most kids
but it didn't pop into my head
when I thought about most influential.
- I felt like I couldn't miss it.
I felt like he would know
if I didn't watch the show.
I felt as if I had a
relationship with the guy.
- I think there was
something about feeling like
I was being taught.
- Mm-hmm.
- The parts I liked and remembered about
Mister Rogers' Neighborhood
was when he would go into,
what was the name of the land?
Whatever land.
- I can't remember.
- And the puppets.
Even though--
- Pretend land?
- Even though he was in those
moments still teaching me,
I don't know, maybe it's
my issue with authority.
When it was just a man sitting
there just saying things
and trying to teach me
lessons, I'd be like boring.
Old man, sweater.
And then I would be, oh,
puppets, now those are cool.
That's just how I
interacted with the show.
- I liked him a lot
better than the puppets.
- Hmm, you were scared of
the puppets a little bit,
weren't you?
A lot of kids were.
- I just didn't like puppets, man.
- 'Cause he did all the voices
and some of them were freaky.
- I could feel there was a hand in there.
Just felt weird, that's wrong.
That's wrong.
Maybe there was a father
figure thing happening,
I don't know.
- Oh Mister Rogers was
your stand-in father.
- (chuckles) Yeah, let's say that.
- Okay.
- I got a kick out of
his son being interviewed
for the documentary.
Great documentary, one
of the best of last year.
I recommend you watch it
if you have any connection
to Mister Rogers.
What's your number nine?
- The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air.
- [Link] Uh-huh.
- Of course you know that
many memes have been created
about this, if you didn't happen to see it
when it happened between 1990 and 1996.
But for me, this was,
this is like the first,
obviously I watched Growing
Pains and Family Ties
and all those sitcoms coming up, but,
this was the first one.
I remember watching the first episode.
And just thinking, this is different, man.
- Well it was for, it was the first one,
I think to complete that
thought, that was made for us.
Like somebody made a show
amongst all these other shows,
like Family Ties was for the family.
Perfect Strangers is, you know--
- Perfect Strangers almost made my list.
- I would almost, I would watch Frasier.
These shows that like--
- I was a fan of Frasier as well.
- Again, there's only so
many shows, so many channels
and nothing's on-demand
so you kinda had to watch
the stuff that was for
adults and just get in
where you fit in.
I do remember that, I
don't know how we knew
that it was coming on.
I don't know how the marketing got to us,
but I remember watching that first,
expecting the first episode,
having been such an
obsessive fan of their music.
- Yeah, already fans of the music.
- And it's whoa, this is the
first show that's made for us.
I'm explaining to my mom.
This is the guy from Parents
Just Don't Understand.
- Right.
- Nightmare On My Street.
- Because there was the whole Cosby Show,
then A Different World
and you kinda felt like
A Different World was a little bit more,
because it was college, it
was reaching a little bit more
into our age group and I
watched it and liked it
but this was all of a sudden,
it was the age that we were
that in 1990, I was like 13.
- Mm-hmm.
- And so when it started,
I was just about to begin
this whole high school experience
and so it was the perfect time.
And I just thought everything
about it was perfect.
It was incredibly, and
let me tell you right now.
- Yeah.
- It does hold up.
Because my kids--
- It really does, yeah.
- My kids got into watching
The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
a couple years ago when it was--
- Mine too.
- On whatever platform
it was on, you can still get it,
but they ended up watching
every single episode.
In like a few months, like
every time I got home,
they would be watching another
episode of The Fresh Prince
and then telling me about
what they were getting into
and I would sit down and watch some of it,
obviously it's ridiculous in a lot of ways
but for me, it changed the way I thought
about half hour sitcom,
like studio-based sitcoms.
- Yeah.
- And exactly what you said.
It felt like it was for me.
- And Will Smith, before he
started his YouTube channel,
I think it's on another YouTube channel,
it might have been right
when he, no, I take it back.
When he started his YouTube
channel, he told a story.
If you're into The Fresh
Prince, you gotta look this up.
The story of The Fresh Prince being made.
I kinda don't wanna spoil it but,
my mind was blown by the fact that as big
as a celebrity he was, like I
don't know if he won a Grammy,
Grammy-nominated, like he was broke.
And he tells this story of he's
over at Quincy Jones's house
at a party and Quincy Jones has the script
or is talking to a guy who has the script.
I can't remember the story exactly,
but basically he puts him
on the spot to audition
at the party and forces
him to do it even though
he said I'm not ready, I
can't do this right now.
And it was like this make or break moment
for Will Smith even though
from my perspective,
he was like one of the
biggest stars in the world
because he was this
amazingly hilarious rapper.
- Yeah.
- He was like the Mister
Rogers of rapping for me,
like I felt like I had
a relationship with him.
And, but he was broke,
he'd blown all the money.
- He spent all his money, yeah.
- Spent all the money
and he was desperate.
And out of that desperation
came them rewriting the script
that was written for
somebody else for him,
and it became The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air.
He tells the story great.
I'll have to tweet it out.
That is my number five.
- Oh wow.
- So it's higher on my list.
Man, it was just such a special time.
That was back, and then that
next album was gonna come out
which ended up being a flop
but we were like waiting
for it and we didn't know when,
we didn't have information.
- There was no internet.
- So I remember waiting--
- Nobody's talking about this
on the news.
- I remember going to--
- Especially if you didn't have cable.
I didn't have cable at my
house so there's no MTV.
- Yeah every weekend I'd
go to get my mom to take me
to Record Bar and I would
just hope it would be there.
And then I finally asked him
and it turns out the people there,
they knew when albums were coming out.
They said, "Oh, three more
weeks, it's coming out."
I couldn't wait.
- But to answer your question
about how we found out
about television shows,
it was commercials.
You'd be watching a show and
there would be a commercial
and you would learn,
oh, there's a new show
that's got The Fresh Prince in it.
And you would be like,
when is that coming on,
and they would tell you
and you would watch it.
That was the only way you
found out about things.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it wasn't like
there was billboards and--
- And you could set your VCR to tape it
but I never did that.
You'd miss 'em or you'd
get 'em on the re-run.
- Yeah we never ever did that.
- My number nine is, I
think you've alluded to it
later in your list, The Dukes of Hazzard.
- [Rhett] Yes.
- So--
- Number four for me.
- Whoa, number four for you?
- Yeah.
- Dukes of Hazzard ran from 1979 to 1985
and I don't know at what point
Bo and Luke were replaced
by their cousins.
- I mean in my mind it's pretty late.
- I did not watch that.
- No I tried.
- That was a huge betrayal
of what I was interested in.
I thought they were the same guys.
I thought they did what
they did years later
with The Fresh Prince's aunt.
Like the actress changed.
- Yeah.
- After like,
next season comes back it's
like, she's a different woman.
- Aunt Viv.
But anyway, I mean it was just southern,
you got this General Lee
car which you can't do that.
- No no.
- Like I don't even,
I'm not even gonna say
that's a good thing.
- But I will say that half of the fan mail
that was sent to the show was
addressed to the General Lee.
(both chuckle)
Fun fact.
- Seriously?
- Yes.
- I mean that,
that racist car was a character
on the show, wasn't it?
- I had the car--
- it wasn't like KITT
from Knight Rider which
did not make my list.
- It didn't have a personality.
It had a Confederate flag
on the top of the car.
- Right.
- And I had that car
just to give you, this is
just the way we grew up,
I had that car, that
model car in my house,
on my shelf and I had a bunch
of Dukes of Hazzard toys,
and I had a Dukes of Hazzard cup
that I think I still have in my house.
- We didn't call it Dukes of Hazzard.
Like you said the first
time, Dukes o' Hazzard.
- Dukes o' Hazzard.
- I didn't even know
that Hazzard was a county really.
I didn't, to me, Dukes o'
Hazzard was just one word
that meant every Thursday
night, I go to my Nanny's house
and we're gonna watch The Dukes of Hazzard
and then when that's over,
I have to sit there
while they watch Dallas
which came on right after.
- Not quite the same.
- That was not, I was
not into that at all.
There was kissing on that.
- The reason that it's so
high in my list is because,
like The A-Team, it's
one of the first shows
that I could remember being
appointment television
for my family but The Dukes
o' Hazzard was the thing
that I thought about as early
as I can remember television.
And Cole and I, my brother and I would,
sometimes we would dress
up like Bo and Luke.
'Cause he had darker hair and I had,
my hair was pretty blonde at the time
and we would dress up like them
sometimes to watch the show.
And then--
- You were cosplaying.
- And then, so the show was
on, you said through 79 to 85,
so when I moved to
California, now, you may,
if you watch the show, you kinda
see the car running around,
and you're like that's
not Georgia. (chuckles)
That doesn't look like Georgia,
that looks like California.
And of course I didn't know
what California looked like.
We moved to California
in 1984 and my dad says,
"I'm gonna take you to where they film
"The Dukes of Hazzard."
And so he took us out to, I
don't remember where it was,
but it was the place that they would shoot
all the car scenes, the
General Lee flying over
in the river, doing all
the stunts and stuff.
- Yeah it was like demolition derby.
- And it was just that--
- There would be a scene
in every episode that would be like--
- Oh yeah.
- The car doing some epic jump.
- The car would do a jump
and then it would pause
and then Waylon Jennings would say,
"Now, these boys didn't know
what was about to happen."
And then it would go to commercial--
- It's so great.
- And then it would come back
and un-pause the car and
then the car would land.
I mean, everything about that
show at the time in my life
and the way that I was
taking in entertainment,
it just, it checked all the boxes.
- It wasn't, I mean except
for the filming location,
it was so distinctly southern.
I felt like it was a documentary.
When I turned off the television
and got back in the car,
I was driving around in Hazzard County.
- Well I don't know how
well you remember it
because you remember
there's like Boss Hogg.
Did you know anybody who
wore a all-white suit
with a top hat?
- Almost.
I'm telling you.
- In my world it wasn't
quite that extreme.
- It was, you know with
my relatives in my world.
- Okay, I get it.
- I felt like it was just
a reflection of reality, except
for the way the cars behaved
when they hit obstacles,
they would somehow just be
ejaculated into the air.
- Whoa, okay.
That's a word.
- Or projected into the air
is what maybe I should have said.
- Yeah, they probably didn't use that word
on The Dukes of Hazzard.
- I had a play set where
you'd rev up the car
and you'd let it go on the thing
and it would go through a
barn and it had a ramp inside
of the barn and when it came
out the other side of the barn,
it would turn on its side
and then do a barrel roll and land,
and I had that set at
my Nanny's house too.
So yeah we'd watch that together.
I mean it was just, it was magical, man.
- Well we should move on,
we've got a lot to go.
- What's your number nine?
Your number eight.
- Number eight,
Animaniacs.
- Wow, we really do have
a lot of similar, I thought
our lists was gonna be
totally different
honestly, I don't know why.
- So what number is Animaniacs for you?
- Animaniacs is number six for me.
- Okay.
- So we're around the same area.
- So I think the guy
who has it ranked higher
should start talking about it.
- So that was from 1993 to 1998.
I remember watching it after school.
- Yep.
- I don't know that I
could have articulated it.
I guess I would have to.
It was the humor,
I mean it was--
- So specific.
- Absolutely the specific jokes.
I mean like Pinky and the Brain I'm gonna,
it had its own spin-off show later
which I've never actually
watched, but that was gold.
And then the way that
the Animaniacs would,
they would, I think there was innuendo.
It was all types of, I
mean it was very joke-heavy
and it was very, there
was a lot of winking
at the older audience.
- You felt--
- And I was just old enough
to know that was happening.
- Yeah you felt like you were, well,
I'm sure there was other things obviously,
The Simpsons which did not make my list,
was happening around the same time,
but something about the darkness
and the weirdness that was
the Animaniacs world view,
and the way that they saw things
and the way that they pointed out things
and the way that they talked about things,
it was a little bit of that
old school Warner Brothers,
you know, crazy physical thing
but then it brought this second
layer of smart, dark humor.
It was subversive and it was
hitting exactly the right time,
in 93 to 98 so I was watching
it basically in high school,
like you said and at that time,
because by the time you're in high school,
schedules get crazy, it
would come on after school
and so it was one of those things that
I didn't always see
but I never didn't stop
and watch it if it was on.
And yeah, again, to me,
it made the list because of how
it was revolutionary.
I think most of the
things in the list for me
were revolutionary in their own right
and that's what made them
revolutionary in my own life.
- I think it would be higher on my list
if I would have moved onto
watching other animated comedies,
which now is its own genre.
I mean you talk about you got
the whole Adult Swim of it all
and I mean, yeah, The Simpsons
obviously didn't make my list
because I'm still embarrassed
to say I've never watched
a complete episode of The Simpsons.
It was one of those things that
I think I was, at a young age I was told
you're not supposed to watch it.
- We weren't allowed to watch it--
- When it was happening.
Early years.
- Early years
and then I just wasn't a subversive kid
so whenever I was told
not to do something,
then I'd just think, I
said oh, I guess that means
all the way into forever
when the show is like
the most amazing show in
the history of television,
not just animation.
The longest running, I don't
know what the record is, but--
- And I've seen The Simpsons.
The reason it didn't
make my list is because,
it didn't influence me,
it wasn't as impactful.
And I appreciate the show,
I think the show is funny.
I think that Family Guy
is significantly funnier,
personally.
Family Guy did not make
my list either, though.
Because they just didn't,
they got crowded out
by things that were more
influential and more impactful.
- I'm gonna go with my number eight.
Flight of the Conchords,
season one aired in 2007.
And I felt like I had
to put it on the list
because from a professional standpoint,
it's still something that whenever we talk
about scripted projects,
we can't not mention it.
I mean even whenever we
talk about our music,
and we've talked about this in the past,
about how I even have
this chip on my shoulder
against those guys because
I think they're so talented
and that the show was so great.
But it still has ripple effects
through how we do things
because we have to run interference with
how much do we wanna be compared
with anything we're developing,
versus contrasted with it.
- Well and thankfully,
they only did it for two seasons.
- Yeah, over a decade ago.
- I'll say that, I think
one of the best things
that ever happened to us is the fact
that Flight of the Conchords decided
to do things on their own. (chuckles)
You know, 'cause I just think,
and they are playing again.
I think, did Bret's arm ever heal?
I don't know what the latest of that was,
but they are playing together again.
We've been huge fans for a long time.
It didn't make my list
honestly just because
I kinda didn't think about when I was--
- From a professional
standpoint I felt like
it had to make my list.
- Yeah.
Well, and not just--
- I mean it's great.
I mean the tone of it.
The fact, and I'll say specifically,
the fact that it was on HBO
but it was such a specific,
quirky tone that instead
of going over an edge,
or saying okay, the pilot
episode's gotta have nudity in it.
I don't care what it
is because it's on HBO.
You know, they were playing
by their own sets of rules.
- They found their edge
in a different place.
- Right.
- They found their edge
in the fact that they were weird.
- And that's very inspirational to us.
- And obviously the fact
that they incorporated music,
I mean, for years when we talked about
what our scripted idea would be,
our first scripted idea which
ended up being Buddy System,
obviously we had to
weight it against the fact
that we knew we were gonna do music videos
but how do we do this
without being compared
to Flight of the Conchords?
Turns out the way you do it is just do it
and have nobody see
the show that you made.
That's the greatest way to not be compared
to Flight of the Conchords.
- That's a different chip on our shoulder.
(Rhett chuckles)
Let's not bring too many into this.
What's your next one?
- Number seven, The Office.
- Okay.
My number seven is The Office.
We've aligned.
- Oh really?
- Yes.
- Wow, okay.
- The Office ran from 2005 to 2013.
- Yeah and for me this was,
what The Office represents
for me is sort of my homecoming
to half-hour comedy, right?
- Yep.
- So there was this period of time--
- College.
- College where your schedule,
college is about movies.
At least it was--
- For us.
- Mm-hmm.
- That was our discovery--
- And Jerry Springer.
- Of movies, of being able to
watch whatever you wanted to.
There's nobody there to tell
you you can't rent that,
that you're not old enough to see that
and you just watch all these movies.
- Talking about porn.
- No, not talking about porn specifically.
That's a different story,
we could do another podcast on that.
That was what the--
- That's what it sounded like
you were talking about.
- That's what the
computer lab in the library was for.
But specifically, college was about movies
and so then, of course,
there was, it was the south
and we got married right
out of school and--
- Got married in 2000,
you got married in 2001.
It started in 2005.
- And we were watching Survivor!
You know what I'm saying?
- Right, yeah.
- And by that point, Seinfeld was off.
So you could watch reruns of whatever.
But you're kinda sitting
around waiting for
something good and I just
remember all of a sudden,
and again, I know...
The British Office is better.
- Oh gosh.
Don't give me that.
- Shut up!
Shut up about that!
We know it came from England.
We know they're funnier.
We know they start everything
and we just bite it.
We've been through that.
But--
- But it is different.
We make it different.
- Yeah we make it different and we make it
for longer as well.
We run it into the ground.
- So we both started with
season one of The Office
and I just watched it for a few years
but then kinda fizzled out.
I think it was the advent
of children into my life,
well no.
Lily was born in 2003.
- She was born the year that it started.
No no, 2005 was when it started.
Yeah Locke was one when
I started watching it.
- I don't know why I fizzled
out from watching it,
but I will say that when we
were hanging out with Britton
when he was on lockdown
'cause he was on The Voice,
he was just binge-watching
The Office so he talked
to my kids about it a lot
and then Lily started watching The Office
and Lincoln got into it and
now Lando's gotten into it
and we all have started
watching The Office
and I'm watching, I got
in in their stream, right?
So now I'm watching,
we're watching the final
Steve Carell season together.
- Oh wow.
- And I've actually,
you know, The Office was my favorite show,
but again, I didn't get to this
point for some life reason.
I'm watching it for the first
time and let me tell you,
it, at least that season,
I don't know if it hit a lull
before it or after he left--
- It hits a lull after that.
It takes some time to find
some footing without Steve.
- Have you seen it?
'Cause I will say, it's masterful writing.
The way that these characters
that you're attached to,
the way that they use them
and it's just everything
about the way they construct episodes
to give a growing sense of he's leaving
but also a sense of closure
that's not the finale of the season.
It happens--
- Yeah.
- Kind of in the middle of the season
and then what they did afterward,
with the people that
they bring in and the way
that they made a transition
I thought was as brilliant
as you could hope for.
- Well to me the reason that The Office
was so revolutionary, so
influential for me personally,
again, it was innovative, right?
We take it for granted,
but at least it was,
for me it was the first
thing that popularized
this whole breaking the fourth
wall as part of the show.
- Right.
Which is a credit I guess
to the Ricky Gervais--
- Right.
- Steve Merchant or whatever his name is--
- But I'm saying when it got to me,
it was the American version.
It was just so, like,
it was so specifically funny
and it was on network but it wasn't trying
to be a show for your parents.
It wasn't like, we gotta do
this and we gotta take this out
and that's a little too
weird so let's not go there.
- Laugh tracks and none of that.
- Yeah, right, again, first one,
first real half hour
that I cared about that--
- Was a single cam.
So it was revolutionary
and of course then you got
Parks and Rec, which was,
it didn't make my list
because I just feel like it
was just like The Office.
I may actually like it
more as a show ultimately,
but The Office was so influential
and those shows, The Office especially,
has had this incredible resurgence.
I was looking at the Netflix stats.
You know me and the Netflix
stats, I'm always in there.
- I didn't know those were public.
- They recently published
what is the most streamed,
what is most streamed on the platform.
- Okay.
- I don't remember,
Office may have been number
one, I can't remember,
but it was very high up on the list
of just the number of hours of
shows that had been streamed.
And The Office, Parks
and Rec's really high,
because all these, our
kids are now, again,
my kids watch The Office
and there's all these memes
related to The Office.
- And there's this thing
that struck me was like,
everybody is stupid.
Like, I'd forgotten.
And I felt like I didn't have an appetite
for the whole sitcom, like
this suspension of disbelief
in order to like, no one
ever talks like this.
No one is this extreme.
There's gotta be something
to ground this thing.
There's none of that.
But it's so masterful
that you get over it,
but I actually thought,
I actually thought that
I couldn't get into The
Office or The Good Place
or any network sitcoms
anymore, even the best ones,
and I think they're both amongst it.
Because I just thought I was more of a,
I don't really watch comedies.
I watch, ever since Breaking
Bad, I'm just into gritty...
You can have humor in something
but I just don't have an
appetite for comedy anymore
and I thought I'd lost it.
And I've regained it.
- Congratulations.
- Thanks to The Office,
and by the way, I'm crying,
especially at this pocket of this season,
I'm crying just as much as I'm laughing.
- Oh yeah.
- It's so,
they're so good at it!
- Yeah.
- But it's such a suspend
your disbelief world, right?
I mean, the whole sitcom
thing, the way that--
- Yeah.
We're gonna have to get moving fast here.
- What if some are really special?
Just keep going.
- Number six for me, Alias.
- All right we're overlapping again.
Alias I'm putting up at my number three.
- Whoa ho ho ho ho.
- I think it represents
a new genre of watching.
I think we'll say the
same thing so go for it.
- Well yeah, well no you go
'cause it's your number three.
- This ran from 2004 to only 2005?
Did I get that right?
Probably not, but--
- No, 2001 to 2006.
- Okay I don't know why I wrote that.
Oh I know what it--
- Because you watched in 2005.
- That's right, I watched it--
- That's why it's on my
list for the same reason.
- It's on my list higher
because it was the first thing
I ever watched, not streaming,
but on mail-order DVD.
- First television show that you binged.
- That I binge-watched.
- That's why it's on my list.
- And it was great.
Every episode, it was kinda
self-containing but not really
'cause it would have a
cliff-hanger at the end.
You'd have to watch the next one.
And then lo and behold, 'cause
I'm a few seasons behind
and I have Blockbuster
video by mail, not Netflix.
I can watch, I can have
two disks mailed to me.
I can take one into
Blockbuster, hand it in
and get the next Alias there
while the other one's coming in the mail.
I had a whole system.
- Yeah.
- Couldn't do that
with Netflix at the time.
- 'Cause I do think that
it's important to, you know,
because it was a very
significant part of our marriage
of like, now we sit down and
we watch a television show
every single night
until we've gone through
the entire season, bingeing.
- Never done that before.
- That was a novel concept that just a few
of our friends were starting to do.
The first season, we
watched the physical DVDs
that somebody had bought
and then given to us.
- Yep.
- And then we transitioned into
the Blockbuster mail order thing.
And I think, I don't think the show,
she wants to go back and watch it.
Jessie's like, we should
watch it again with the kids,
and I'm like, all right we can try that.
We did that with Lost,
which almost made my list, but didn't.
And I think Lost did hold up.
I don't think that Alias is gonna hold up.
I don't think that it
was masterful television.
- J.J. Abrams is making a
new show with Sydney Bristow.
Jennifer Garner.
- Okay.
I just think that it was--
- Just watch that one.
- It was, again, innovative,
ahead of its time, and--
- It changed how we watched television.
- It hit us at the exact
right time, and of course,
it's the only way that
you watch television now.
I mean obviously some people,
if there's a show that's
released on a weekly basis,
we'll watch it, but--
- I kinda tracked, when
we were out of that,
we watched Friday Night
Lights, we binged all of that.
- Oh gosh.
- We watched House,
which is a great show.
We watched West Wing, we watched 24.
Which Kiefer Sutherland
hasn't even watched
a complete episode of 24.
Gotcha.
- Is that a--
- Fun fact.
- Prison Break and Lost.
All of a sudden you get
into this binge thing where
it's like well I don't need
appointment viewing anymore,
so that's why, I put it
pretty high on my list
'cause it just changed habits.
- Yeah.
- What's your next one?
- Number five is Northern Exposure.
- Northern Exposure.
Northern Exposure's my number four.
- Oh wow.
- I keep beating you.
It's like at some point,
you must have things
higher on your list that
I don't have at all.
- That might be the case.
- I don't know what is happening
at the end of your list.
Northern Exposure ran from 1990 to 1995.
♪ Wah bwa-wa bwa-wa wah wah ♪
- It's funny that a lot of
the things that we really like
are in this early 90s to mid-90s.
- I love a good world.
I mean, Joel Fleischman,
this Jewish doctor
is shipped off to Alaska
to work in this village
and he's like a fish out of water
and he wears a puffy vest and--
- He meets Maggie.
- Who has--
- Short hair.
- And then there was the old guy who was--
- Maurice.
- Maurice was the ex-astronaut.
- Oh, Harlan or something like that.
- Yeah his arch rival
who then became friends
but because they were both
doting over the same girl
who was like 18 and then they got married.
Everything was weird--
- Kelly.
- You just felt really
weird about watching it
but like it was so good.
- And then there was the DJ.
Now, I'm sure that some of these tropes,
they were pulling on previous television.
But you had the really smooth-talking,
he wasn't smooth-talking,
he was just like,
had this silky, smooth
voice and he was super nice,
the DJ who would kinda help
you understand the world
and the way that he talked and--
- You had this feeling of living there.
- It was not the first, because the show
that I'll talk about
that's higher up on my list
is the first show that made
me cry at a television show.
- Okay.
- But I cried at this television show.
And it was also, for me,
one of the first shows
that I watched alone.
- I watched it alone too.
- So I was making that
transition into a place
where okay, my parents
have a TV downstairs,
in their bedroom by this
point when I'm in high school.
There's a television in the living room
and then there's a television in
what we called the extra room which was
that little room upstairs.
And this is when I would
go into the extra room
and I would watch Northern Exposure
and I would just kinda sit
there and just be so immersed.
There was nothing
between me and the world.
I was in there, my mind, my
heart were completely committed
to this character and this world--
- It was quirky.
- And then I would just
find myself laughing and
crying at the same time.
- It was, and it was comedy
written into character quirks,
not written into jokes.
It was a drama, it was a dramedy,
but it wasn't joke-oriented.
And I actually think
that's something that,
it is a big influence
on us in terms of like,
you wanna build a funny world.
You wanna build a quirky,
you wanna build weirdness
into characters and setting.
And that can carry a lot of the comedy.
So it's not about a barrage of jokes.
It's about relationships and moving,
moving a viewer.
- And I don't think that,
you know, I don't think we've
made anything like that yet.
- But that is our aspiration.
- It's influenced us and we
wanna make something like that.
But I think that, you
know, the main expression
of scripted that we've got
in Buddy System is very,
very joke-heavy and is super surreal.
It's weird but it's also like absurdist.
And we love that and wanna
make that kinda thing
and wanna make more of it but yeah.
I think that what we connect with the most
is that thing that is that
mix of, it's that dramedy.
It's what we enjoy the most.
It's also kind of intimidating
to get that right.
It's easier to do just
crazy, joke-heavy comedy.
'Cause you always move onto the next joke.
You're not connecting with this character,
maybe you're laughing at him.
- Yeah.
All right give me your next one
'cause I only have two left.
I got my number two--
- What's your number five?
- My number five is Fresh Prince.
My number four is Northern Exposure.
My number three is Alias.
- My number four is Dukes of Hazzard.
We've already talked about that,
which moves me to number three.
Which is SNL.
- SNL is your number three, okay.
SNL is my number two!
- Okay.
- (laughs) So I think my
list is just your list
notched up a couple.
- Okay.
- Now of course SNL is
running since the 70s forever.
Still going.
- Oh it's still going?
- Yeah, it's still going.
- I didn't know.
- I watched the Matt Damon
Christmas episode on my phone
in bed, I was like, man,
this is the first time
I've watched SNL in years.
I watched one clip and then I
ended up watching everything.
Just laughing out loud, I was like,
I'm really glad that this is really funny.
- Well and it may strike
you, I don't know,
depending how old you are.
If your age, this probably
makes a lot of sense.
If you're younger, this may be what?
This may be a little
bit of a head scratcher,
but I think that Lorne
Michaels said it best
when he said that everyone's favorite era
of SNL is when they were in high school.
And that--
- Potentially middle school.
'Cause I think for us--
- Well started in middle school.
- It absolutely started in middle school,
and I mean, yeah that's
my favorite season.
I think there was, it
was actually in the midst
of a big transition period
'cause I kinda looked into this
a little bit, 'cause I remembered,
I remembered Chris Rock.
And then, his last season was,
I remember Norm Macdonald
hosting Weekend Update
and that was the first season
that Chris Rock was gone.
Norm was there the year
before but you know,
and then Chris Farley coming in.
Will Ferrell came in but it was
when, why am I losing the name,
the Canadian dude from Wayne's World.
What's his name?
- Mike Myers.
- Yeah, Mike Myers.
He was leaving, but a lot of people say
it wasn't a strong point,
but for us it was all we had.
- Yeah.
- And if you could,
you'd stay up as late as you could
and then we'd have to get up
and go to church the next morning.
We would skip out on Sunday
school, staying in the hallway
and just talk about the sketches.
- Yeah.
- You remember that?
- Oh yeah--
- We just obsessed over
the impersonation--
- We talked about this in the,
earlier, I don't remember how long
the Deep Thoughts by Jack Handey ran--
- That's right.
- But that was a big thing for us.
- Yeah.
- We actually just, that
was inserted in something
that we're working on right
now that we'll talk about soon.
- That's right, we put
a reference in there,
and it's also in the--
- In the Book of Mythicality.
- Yeah you see in the inserts
to our church bulletin,
we would write our versions of
Deep Thoughts by Jack Handey.
- That weren't actually funny.
- It was some of our first comedy writing.
- And then we met, who did we
meet that had a connection?
- John Fortenberry directed
season one of Buddy System--
- Yes.
- And he worked on Deep Thoughts.
- He worked on Deep Thoughts.
- I was gonna say co-created
but I don't know if that's true.
He worked with--
- I think he worked with Jack,
maybe directed those spots.
- That's right 'cause Jack
Handey was a real person,
a writer on SNL.
- And Jack Handey, I looked him up
when I was thinking about this,
continues to write.
He had a number of Deep Thoughts books.
The first one published in 91 or 92,
which is why it's referenced.
And he's like self-publishing,
he kept doing it.
And he's still a humorist
that does these absurd things,
but anyway--
- Also Adam Sandler's songs.
I mean you start to think
about, it really plants a seed,
I believe in our minds that
like, we can write funny songs.
We can do that.
- It was really our only
exposure to sketch comedy.
- Absolutely.
- We didn't watch stand-up.
I would watch stand-up on
a Showtime at the Apollo.
Or I would watch like a Sinbad special.
And I just thought that
Sinbad's comedy specials
were the most incredible
thing I'd ever seen.
- But very unapproacable.
- We weren't really
students of comedy in that.
We didn't have anybody,
stand-up wasn't a thing.
We weren't listening to like
old tapes of George Carlin
or whatever, a lot of
people coming up in comedy
were getting that but we just
came from a different place,
so we had NBC on Saturday night and--
- If you could stay up, yeah
there was like this reward
of like, oh if you can sneak
and stay up late enough
and stay awake--
- If you can stay up after SNL,
you can watch Party in Progress.
- Oh goodness, that's right.
- Remember that?
- Oh yeah, it was just--
- Is that still a thing?
- No.
- Party in Progress--
- It was a half hour show.
- No, all it was was a
bunch of girls in bikinis--
- At parties.
- At parties
and they would just film all of that.
- I think they just went to Daytona Beach
for like two weeks.
- In my 16 year old mind,
it was the best thing that
anyone could have caught on film.
It was revolutionary and I was hoping
that no one would walk in.
- It was just people
filming bikini contests
at Daytona Beach and just
turning it into a show--
- A show for us.
- For people in colder regions.
- Thought it was made just for me.
I thought it was only
broadcast to my television.
(Link chuckles)
- I think I've told the story before,
but I gotta mention it again.
The Nielsen ratings people
sent worksheets to our house.
For some reason my mom
agreed to participate--
- I forgot about this.
- In the Nielsen ratings thing
where you would write down
what shows you watched.
Every night, you'd keep a log
and then you would mail in--
- And you were literally a Neal's son.
Which is, made it very appropriate.
- Conflict of interest, perhaps.
So we'd hand write the stuff we'd watch.
We'd watch Entertainment
Tonight every night.
And then we'd watch, I don't know,
all the other stuff we watched,
but then I remember my
mom set it up to mail it
and I snuck, opened it and
added Party in Progress.
(Rhett laughs)
Because I wanted--
- In bold.
- I had to do--
- Don't drop that Party in Progress.
- I had to do my part to keep
Party in Progress in progress.
(Rhett laughs)
But I didn't want my mom to know.
Uh, yeah.
- Party in Progress is my number one.
I'll just go ahead--
(Link laughs)
Just go ahead and cut to the chase.
- Oh man.
- No it did not make the list.
- I gotta google that just
to see if it still exists.
It's like, just bikini contests.
That is my number two.
I feel like it permeated
our comedic sensibility
to the point that it
earned the next top spot.
I'm just saying.
- Yeah and this was not
easy, this wasn't easy, but--
- I accept your apology.
What is your next?
- My number two is
The Wonder Years.
- Oh.
- Not even on your list.
- No.
Never watched it but I knew
it would be on your list.
- Okay so this ran from 1988
to 1993, starred Fred Savage.
And the narrator was
Daniel Stern who was--
- Really?
- Yeah.
Every single episode--
- Your doppelganger
from Home Alone.
- Yes, does all the narration
as the adult version
of Kevin, Kevin Arnold,
looking back on his life
growing up in the 60s and 70s.
And it
captured me.
So all those things I said
about Northern Exposure
are twice as true.
So this is, I mean,
I'm talking, and again,
this was the first show
that I watched by myself.
- Okay.
- And 'cause my parents
didn't care about this show.
My brother was into other things,
and so it just hit me at this time.
And I'm watching it, so Kevin
is playing like a 12 year old,
right, and I'm starting
to watch this thing
in 1988 when I'm 11.
- Yeah.
- So he's got this
relationship with Winnie.
- I remember Winnie.
- He's got, she's really great at math.
Super smart,
and then he's got--
- She had bangs.
- He's got his best friend Paul.
And he's got his older brother
who was a bully to him.
So many things about his
life were exact parallels
to what I was going through.
I had an older brother
who would hold me down
and dangle spit over my face
just like his older brother.
Wayne was his name.
And--
- But you had a friend,
that was me, I assume.
- You were just like Paul.
You didn't have glasses at the time.
- Paul was like a--
- Nerd.
- Nerd, I wasn't a nerd.
- Well you may have not thought you were.
But--
(chuckles)
- What about a Winnie?
You didn't have, who was your Winnie?
- Well you always have a Winnie.
You always have the girl--
- In your mind.
- You have the girl that you're, for me,
I always had a girl that I was fixated on.
It just rotated and was a
failure nine times out of 10.
- There was no comedy in
that, it was just drama.
It was like, the feels.
- Wrong.
There was comedy.
It was funny.
It was funny in exactly the same way
that Northern Exposure was.
- Oh really?
- Maybe not as quirky
as Northern Exposure.
But no, it was funny.
I have a feeling it holds up.
I don't know, I haven't ever
gone back and watched it.
Would love to watch it with the kids
because it was already--
- But you'd pretty much
cry every episode, right?
- Well so what I remember is,
I remember being in the
extra room, and again,
just like weeping.
Like, I was so invested.
And crying to the point that I really hope
that my mom doesn't need
anything from me right now
because I'm so invested
in The Wonder Years.
- That was the same feeling you
felt about Party in Progress
but for different reasons.
- Exactly, and I don't know,
it was so well done and I felt like I was,
interestingly I felt like I
was getting this insight into,
I wasn't exactly getting insight
into my parent's perspective
because they were,
the generational gap, so I
was the age of the people
playing the kids but it was from a time
that was a little bit after
my parents were that age.
- [Link] Mm-hmm.
- I don't know how that would have
worked out mathematically,
that would have been perfect,
but I don't know, I just
felt like you got this,
every character was so well developed
and so relatable.
- Do you remember a moment
like what was the defining moment?
Do you remember the finale?
- No, my brain doesn't work like that.
I have a horrible memory when
it comes to the specifics.
I just remember the vibe
and the general feel.
But the way that he thought about Winnie.
The way that he thought about girls
and his friendships, it
was just so relatable,
'cause you know me.
I, at that age, at age 11 or 12,
I was already completely
obsessed with girls.
I wasn't a late bloomer.
And so I already was
fixated on different girls
and imagining what a relationship,
oh if she was just my girlfriend,
then everything would be great.
And if she was my girlfriend,
it would be the only
thing that I cared about.
And I felt like he kind
of embodied that in a way,
just the way that he was
dealing with everything.
It was the most relatable thing
and it was just incredibly well-done.
- It was very dramatic.
I just didn't have an appetite
for that drama at that point.
- But you liked Northern Exposure
but you liked Northern Exposure later.
'Cause this happened earlier.
- Yeah, right.
- 'Cause you would have been 10 years old
or so when it started.
- Well it seems that we
are each to our number one.
And I pretty much know at this point
that we agree, 'cause we both left off,
it's just painfully obvious at this point
that we agree on our number
one and isn't that fabulous?
- Yes it is.
- So our number one is Green Acres.
I actually watched Green Acres.
- I didn't.
- I watched reruns of that.
- Seriously, our number one is--
- [Both] Seinfeld.
- Absolutely.
So Seinfeld ran from 1989 to 1998.
So once it really hit its stride
after a couple of seasons,
it was in our high school sweet spot
when it was in its sweet spot.
And I remember, again,
appointment viewing.
I'd hunker down in my bed,
I'd get my homework done
or I'd say, well it's gotta wait.
And if, I would tell Mom
I'm watching Seinfeld
in my room, hold my calls.
(chuckles)
I remember Michael Jubie
called me to do some homework
and it was like, I answered
the phone 10 minutes
before it came on and talked
to him for nine minutes
and then I was like, hey dude.
I know this conversation's
not anywhere near over
but I gotta go 'cause
Seinfeld's coming on.
I was not going to miss it.
- Yeah.
- It was so, the comedic
voice was so specific
and so unique to anything
I had been exposed to.
I think we were primed for
that Larry David cynicism,
because though we didn't watch Letterman,
I mean your dad had that dry wit
and we resonated with that sense of humor.
- I watched a little
Letterman, at the same time.
- I just think that we were,
that type of observational
dry sense of humor
was something that really
resonated with us and we hadn't--
- Well it was the kind thing where
when they were riffing on something,
you weren't just laughing at it,
you were reveling in it.
You know what I'm saying, so like,
you were so blown away by the
choices that were being made
and the way that the jokes were coming,
the way that the jokes would just happen
and then the way that the
whole story would come together
at the end and these ridiculous plot lines
would come together in
this completely stupid way.
- Yeah.
They would weave three stories.
- It was like--
- And it would all pay off
in one moment.
- It was like grabbing something
that has the exact same
vibrational energy, like
you grab onto something
that is vibrating at the frequency
that your body is vibrating
at and it creates this,
and I know that sounds crazy, and listen--
- But it felt, you could feel it.
- Yeah it is, it transcended.
And now, let me just address something.
Now, Ethan of h3h3 did an incredible job
of addressing this when he reacted to
the react video.
- Teens react.
- Where the teens were
reacting to Seinfeld
and basically, just watch that.
Just put h3h3 Seinfeld.
- Yeah 'cause their basic premise--
- And basically, I don't
remember every single thing
that Ethan said but his
perspective is my perspective.
And that is the fact that,
part of it was the fact that
something that was being done on the show,
modern kids felt like, it
made 'em feel uncomfortable,
but they didn't get the joke.
- It seemed culturally
insensitive and I'm sure it was
at certain points but lots
of times, that was the joke.
- Right.
- They were making, it was commentary.
- But a lot of people are like,
I don't understand why it's funny.
These characters seem ridiculous.
Everybody's super selfish and
it's like exactly! (chuckles)
- And I didn't, I couldn't
have articulated that,
that like, okay, I mean they talked about
how it's a show about nothing,
because they made a show within the show.
They conceptualized the
show within the show.
- Right.
- (chuckles) And then tried to sell it.
Which again, that's just great.
It's just so creative
and self-referential,
but I couldn't have said,
well, Jerry doesn't change.
Like, we're gonna break the rule, like,
that was a ground rule that
I couldn't have articulated.
It's like, well, for successful writing,
the characters have to have an arc.
- Nobody changed.
- Nobody changes.
- Nobody grows.
- Nobody's, they're all bad.
They're bad people.
- Yeah, right.
And they don't grow.
They're all completely self-focused.
- There are characters,
I mean look at House.
A very comedically
self-centered flawed character
but I dropped off, maybe he changes.
It was like, they stuck
to their guns to the end.
- Well I think that--
- Until it got kind
of schmaltzy with this Green Day montage,
but other than that--
- But I think that the reason, again,
this is completely subjective, right.
This is very subjective.
We're not talking about what
the greatest television shows
are of all time, this
is the most influential
and I think that even whatever
you think is the greatest
is so subjective.
It's that thing that I'm talking about.
Some intersection of our
background and our sensibilities
that were some weird combination
of nature and nurture
primed us to be completely
ready to accept this.
I think part of it had to do,
and I think that you articulated the way
that we think about it now with the fact
that all these characters are
selfish and they don't change,
we wouldn't have been able
to say that at the time,
but one of the reasons
I think that appealed
to us is that we were in this,
the culture that we were growing
up in, we were good boys.
And we were being told how to be good boys
and the things that you should believe
and the things that you should,
the way you should behave.
And I think that all of a sudden,
these people from New York
who were all single, didn't have kids,
didn't aspire to get married or have kids,
and were not playing by any of the rules
that all the adults in
our lives were playing by.
- Mm-hmm.
- It was this opposites
attract thing, and like I said,
but we had this yearning
for some kind of release
and instead of going out and
doing irresponsible things,
we watched Seinfeld.
- Like egging houses or--
- We did some irresponsible
things, but we watched Seinfeld.
I think SNL served the same
purpose in a lot of ways.
It was like, it's a way to
kind of revel in this thing
where you kinda need a
break from the setting
that you live in.
And I'm not saying that kids growing up
in New York didn't like
Seinfeld, but for us,
everything just lined up.
And it's the way that we--
- Who was your favorite character?
- Whoa, that's a really good question.
I mean I think it might be...
It might be either Jerry
or George's dad. (laughs)
- George's dad, who is Ben
Stiller's dad in real life.
Kramer's my favorite character.
- Oh yeah, love Kramer, of course.
- Every time he entered,
everyone would cheer.
- Yeah, well he was great.
- 'Cause he would enter,
it was like a throwback.
He was like a throwback to
an earlier time of comedy.
- And he was also the only character
who actually wasn't 100% selfish.
He actually was a good friend.
He was selfish at the same
time, but he was a good friend.
- Yeah.
He was also an ass man.
- Yeah, well, so the--
- That license plate.
- Jon Voight's car, right?
- Yeah.
- So this is something guys our age,
people our age who work in comedy,
you have this just the way
that Larry David thought
kind of constantly
running through your mind
and you're trying to make
sure that you're not just
writing a scene or a joke that is,
well that's just Seinfeld,
or that's what is now
Curb Your Enthusiasm,
which is sort of a remix.
It's so influential that
you just have to make sure
that you're not going there all the time.
And another reason you
don't wanna go there
all the time is because, you know,
20 year old people don't care about it,
don't think it's funny.
It's like they don't
find it funny anymore.
'Cause things change, you're not wrong--
- I was trying to figure out--
- You're different.
- If my kids would be into it, like hey.
You like Parks and Rec,
you like The Office.
I started researching does it hold up?
- They would not, my theory is.
- Of course, people who
love it say it does hold up.
But I'm gonna test it on my kids.
I was talking to 'em about it last night.
You know, Britton's a big influence.
I'm gonna use him.
- Maybe it will hold up
because--
- He said he loved it.
So I betcha I can get my kids to love it.
Here's the one thing that doesn't hold up.
There's a lot of phone humor.
And it's all written before the advent
of cell phones and Google.
Like specifically, I'm not
even saying the internet,
but a lot of phone humor, a lot of--
- Give me an example.
- Answering machine humor.
That's just what I read.
I don't remember an example.
And then I was reading
an article that said
if you're gonna introduce it to somebody,
you should watch it in reverse.
Like, start with season
19 or whatever it was,
watch that forwards but
then watch 18, 17, 16.
I don't know how many seasons.
- It's not that many seasons
'cause it was a scripted show,
I think there's just as many seasons
as there are years, right?
Typically that's how that's done.
- Anyway, that brings
us to our number one.
I do wanna, I don't think
it's on a streaming service,
interestingly enough.
- You can't watch Seinfeld anymore?
- I think you gotta own it.
- Nine seasons.
- You have to get the nine seasons on DVD.
It's at least what I've been told.
We'll have to look into
that but all right,
so we've completed our
list and you hung with us.
This is a longer Ear Biscuit
but thanks for hanging with us.
- And let us know what you
think about this format.
It's something that we might do again.
Okay, you can watch all
of Seinfeld on Hulu.
Jacob just let us know.
- Thank you, Jacob.
- Let us know if you want,
what you thought about
sort of this ranking,
reminiscing kinda thing
'cause obviously we
can do this with things
other than television shows.
I enjoyed talking about it.
- Yeah.
So use #EarBiscuits, let
us know what you thought,
and we'll speak at ya again next week.
- Mm-hmm.
- Can I rattle off my honorable mentions
since we have time to fill?
- Sure.
- Reading Rainbow, Inspector
Gadget, The Jetsons,
A-Team, Small Wonder.
Watched that after school.
Small Wonder, a robot,
in 2007 she was a nurse
in Boulder Community Hospital
in Boulder, Colorado.
I tried to find what
she's up to now, Vicki.
Had a crush on Vicki.
- Hmm.
- Punky Brewster, also had a crush on her.
The Ellen DeGeneres Show.
That almost made my list.
- Hmm.
- 'Cause it's like, it
was the first lesbian
that came into my home every single day.
- Right.
- Of course now I got
all types of lesbians
coming into my home.
- That's right.
- I love it.
- Yep.
- But I mean, she was the first one.
- I didn't watch it.
- Well even now.
I mean not the sitcom, the
show that's still on now.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
- I thought you were
talking about the sitcom.
- It's been on a long time now.
Letterman, The Cosby Show,
The Wire, Breaking Bad
and Mad Men, some of my
favorite television shows.
- That's when you get into
the best television shows
of all time and I'd definitely
be breaking those out.
- And The Price Is Right.
- The only thing on my honorable mention
that you didn't cover on your list
or there was Simon & Simon.
- (chuckles) Good theme song.
- And we also talked
about Perfect Strangers.
- Oh yeah.
- You mentioned it.
That almost made my list as
well, which interestingly,
both our shows are about two guys.
Simon & Simon, private investigators,
the rough and tumble ex-vet
and then the pretty boy,
and then Larry and Balki, that
was the Perfect Strangers.
(sighs) Yeah.
- Let's get--
- Reminiscing.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)